en los vídeos pasados hemos visto esta
idea de como el banco de la reserva
federal establece la oferta de dinero
por medio de determinar pues cierta tasa
de interés objetivo una duda que luego
luego aún no se le ocurre es pues porque
andan estableciendo tasas de interés y
no hacen un objetivo de pues así del de
la oferta de dinero que quieren porque
nos dicen que quieren que m 0 sea igual
a haber dejarlo escribo queremos tener
un m ser objetivo de pues no lo sé 900
mil millones de pesos si ahorita
estuviera en 800 mil millones entonces
nada más tendrían que imprimir el resto
tendrían que ir a la imprenta de dinero
o bien podrían abrir lo equivalente en
cuentas del banco de la reserva federal
el m 0 sería de 900 mil millones habría
más préstamos y con eso aumentamos el m1
de manera similar podrían tener un m un
objetivo recuerda que esto es el m 0
pero además sumando todo para considerar
las cuentas de cheques esencialmente es
todo lo que se usa como uned a efectivo
depósitos de reserva o incluso lo que
está en cuentas de cheques porque con un
cheque puedes pagar algo bueno entonces
podrían poner ese objetivo en no sé dos
billones de pesos
también podrían establecer un objetivo
para el m2 el m2 es el m 0 bueno el m 1
más lo que está en cuentas de ahorro más
el dinero en el mercado a lo mejor
quieren que este total sea 8 billones
bueno seguro ahorita me estoy inventando
los números pero no importa tendremos
que buscar la información para ver qué
tal van las cosas en méxico entonces no
sé estoy aquí nada más son números que
me estoy inventando vale pero bueno la
pregunta es por qué no establecen sus
objetivos en términos de estos números
porque nos dicen por ejemplo que quieren
que m2 sea pues que me 2 siempre sea el
50% del producto interno bruto del país
seguida esos van a ver el 50 por ciento
del producto interno del país entonces
pues parece razonable verdad porque
conforme la economía crece y el dinero
está un poquito bajo pues vamos a tener
que imprimir un poco más de billetes y
con eso hacer un efecto multiplicador y
viceversa si baja podríamos hacer
operaciones en el mercado para revertir
el proceso y quitar tantas reservas del
sistema bancario bueno pues sí o sea la
verdad es es una forma correcta de
pensar las cosas y hay mucha gente que
la apoya y osea en realidad no hay una
mejor respuesta
una respuesta que sea la correcta es
difícil de decir pero estuve pensando y
encontré dos razones para apoyar las
tasas de interés pero como todavía no
acabo de convencerme a mí mismo tal vez
después hago un vídeo para explicarte
porque esto de poner el dinero en el 50%
del producto interno bruto
pues sí podría tener pegue en fin la
primera razón es una así por pura
conveniencia la tasa bancaria con la
cual los bancos se prestan entre sí es
mucho más fácil de medir que estos
indicadores de dinero de acá no sé por
ejemplo si yo fuera el presidente del
banco de mexico y quisiera saber a qué
tasas están prestando los bancos
entonces simplemente hago un estudio del
mercado agarro me paro en un banco y le
pregunto en cuánto estás prestando y me
dice 5.2 por ciento y yo digo chino está
muy alto vamos a tener que comprar más
pagarés federales es súper rápido así lo
obtenemos al instante no hay que esperar
a que se hagan encuestas ni nada por el
estilo por otro lado si quisiera la
información de la oferta de dinero
entonces tendremos que hacer tablas así
supera al instante súper al instante y
entonces pues el evento sería todavía
más latoso tendríamos que hacerle
encuestas a los bancos y llenar todo en
una base de datos así
rápido está dificilísimo y bien la tos o
bueno esa es una razón la otra es un
poco más abstracta pero confío en que si
le vas a agachar mira supongamos que es
que es otoño no no no más bien es
temporada de siembra la temporada de
siembra no soy granjero pero creo que es
en primavera va entonces supongamos que
hay algunos proyectos en los cuales los
granjeros tienen que comprar semillas y
uno de ellos tiene un retorno de el
granjero hace el proyecto sólo se
consigue un préstamo con 20% menos de
interés entonces si alguien le quiere
prestar a 21 por ciento va a decir no no
no no aplica por otro lado si alguien le
ofrece al 19 por ciento más de sirva mi
proyecto si crea tanta riqueza como para
poder pagar los intereses y pagar el
préstamo vamos con otro granjero con un
proyecto de 18 por ciento misma idea se
obtiene un préstamo del 18 por ciento de
interés o menos hace su proyecto vamos a
poner otro más vamos a poner que este de
acá es un granjero con un proyecto con
un proyecto de 12 por ciento si consigue
un préstamo del 11 por ciento ya la hizo
compra sus semillas y las
vale por otro lado que no tiene nada que
ver con cosechas hay otros proyectos
también buenos por ejemplo alguien que
tiene pues una fábrica con una
tecnología súper padre y se va a animar
a construirla siempre y cuando tenga un
financiamiento del 19 por ciento un
financiamiento del 19 por ciento vamos
con otro más vamos pues no sé con otra
fábrica y supongamos que la hace si
consigue 3 por ciento 3 por ciento en
realidad eso quiere decir que no confía
mucho en su fábrica porque pues porque
piensa que sólo tiene sentido hacer la
fábrica si consigue un financiamiento
así súper barato mejor que de 3 por
ciento mi gato ya vino a dar lata pero
bueno sigamos hay otro más hay otro
proyecto que la verdad está súper malo y
él lo sabe dice no tiene sentido hacer
esto a menos que casi casi obtenga
dinero así gratis que tenga un préstamo
súper bajo va así están las cosas en
esta primavera en esta temporada de
siembra todos estos de aquí son clientes
potenciales para dinero que pasa si
asumimos que la oferta de dinero está
fija en este momento no se pensemos que
mira a la oferta de dinero la voy a
dibujar como
entonces hay tres círculos tres círculos
de dinero va entonces esencialmente el
dinero se le va a prestar a las personas
que estén dispuestos a pagar mayor
interés en este caso y para simplificar
un poco las cosas vamos a suponer que es
más o menos un préstamo de la misma
cantidad pero bueno en un sistema
capitalista los mejores tres proyectos
van a obtener el dinero y entonces
cuáles serían serían este este y este
verdad estos tres de aquí obtendrían el
dinero y cuánto van a pagar interés pues
está para pensarlo pero la cosa es que
pagan el menor interés que alguno de
ellos esté dispuesto a pagar va entonces
lo que va a pasar es que el dinero se va
a acabar prestando a una tasa de interés
de digamos 17.9 por ciento
entonces 17.9 por ciento de interés
entonces se le presta a estos tres y
ahorita estamos haciendo todo con muchas
simplificaciones sólo quiero ver
la idea básica y en estos otros
proyectos estos proyectos de acá ya no
se van a realizar esto en parte es bueno
porque estos dos proyectos pues la
verdad estaban un poco malos pero por
otro lado hicieron
proyectos de 12% que si pudiéramos tener
el capital en ese momento entonces le
daría a la sociedad un retorno del 12
por ciento de ganancia no suena nada mal
sin embargo el problema es que no había
capital suficiente no había pues dinero
suficiente para poder financiarlo salehí
vale pero ahora supongamos que la oferta
de dinero permanece constante porque el
banco federal quiere mantenerla así
entonces conforme nos vamos saliendo de
la temporada de siembra estos proyectos
de acá pues como como son de siembra
desaparecen estos proyectos desaparecen
ya no tienen sentido verdad ya no es
temporada de siembra va este ya está en
marcha pero supongamos que hay uno
similar de 19 por ciento de interés y de
repente mira la temporada de siembra se
acabó y los granjeros ya no quieren
dinero además el dinero es constante
entonces quien no tiene ese
financiamiento pues este buen proyecto
pues y si se va a realizar pero estos
dos proyectos que son casi casi
proyectos basura también se van a
realizar y se van a realizar a un
porcentaje bajísimo como a 1 por ciento
de interés
esto está pésimo la oferta de dinero no
fue elástica con respecto a la demanda
como puedes ver esto trae un efecto
negativo a la sociedad verdad en la
temporada de siembra dejamos pasar
algunos proyectos pues que sí eran muy
buenos para el desarrollo proyectos que
debimos haber hecho porque si eran
seguros y luego por haber mantenido la
oferta de dinero entonces proyectos bien
malos se van a realizar esto fue porque
había un montón de dinero por ahí
corriendo y entonces estos proyectos que
son así de malos que incluso podrían
caer en porcentajes negativos a claro
porque recuerda esto de aquí estos
porcentajes es lo que piensan los
emprendedores que van a obtener pero tal
vez se equivocaron y caen en menos 5% y
entonces se destruiría la riqueza vale
entonces ese es el problema de dejar la
oferta de dinero constante a mediano
plazo
por un lado estás dejando pasar algunos
proyectos buenos en ciertas temporadas
en temporadas con mucha oferta de
proyectos y luego dejas que se hagan
algunos proyectos bien malos cuando la
oferta es muy baja sale por otro lado
mira vamos a hacer el mismo escenario
pero creo que ya está un poco
desordenado bueno ahí van otra vez los
granjeros con
tenemos 1 de 20% 1 de 18% y 1 de 12% por
otro lado acá en amarillo voy a poner
los que no son de siembra un 19% un 3% y
un 1%
entonces qué pasa ahora si cambiamos la
oferta de dinero con respecto a una tasa
de interés y recuerda osea la tasa de
fondos federales es la tasa en la cual
los bancos se prestan entre sí pero como
vimos conforme entran más reservas al
sistema bancario pues no sólo bajan las
tasas de las tasas de préstamo
interbancario sino que además aumenta la
capacidad de préstamo de los bancos con
esto se aumenta la oferta de dinero y
como aumentó la oferta de dinero por
todas partes entonces también baja la
tasa con la cual los bancos le prestan a
las personas entonces aumentamos la
cantidad de dinero digamos la cantidad
de reservas hay más dinero por proyecto
y por tanto el costo de pedir prestado
dinero debe de bajar va entonces no sé
digamos que el banco federal establece
que su tasa objetivo es de 5% de
préstamo interbancario pero que eso a su
vez causa que el préstamo a las personas
tengan una tasa del 8
gay del 8%
entonces no es como que dejemos fija la
cantidad de dinero sino que la movamos
de tal forma que la tasa de interés
permanezca fija qué sucede ahora en la
temporada de siembra cuáles proyectos se
van a apoyar pues este este este y este
estos de acá no y luego cuando acaba la
temporada de siembra pues el interés
sigue siendo el mismo tal vez
disminuimos la oferta de dinero para que
esto suceda otra vez esto de aquí lo
logran a nivel interbancario pero como
todo está relacionado entre sí
entonces si tiene sentido hacerlo para
los préstamos a personas ok entonces se
acabó la temporada y algunos de estos
proyectos ya no funcionan cuáles serían
pues estos de acá verdad los proyectos
de siembra antes cuando teníamos una
oferta de dinero constante habíamos
financiado algunos proyectos basura pero
ahora que mantuvimos las tasas de
interés constantes por al menos
relativamente únicamente los proyectos
buenos son los que se apoyan y entonces
no tenemos que preocuparnos porque los
bancos así por urgencia pues estén así
súper ansiosos de apoyar proyectos por
muy malos que sean
y pues entonces ese es mi punto de vista
ese es mi punto de vista de por qué
tiene más sentido utilizar tasas de
interés en vez de manejar el dinero
permite que la cantidad de dinero se
vaya expandiendo contrayendo
naturalmente según sea la demanda esto
es justo porque establecer una tasa de
interés establece un cierto umbral en el
cual estás dispuesto a prestar
pues según qué tan bueno sea el proyecto
si queda debajo del umbral lo
consideraremos una pérdida de dinero en
fin ya discutiremos esto con más calma
desde otros puntos de vista y con otros
ángulos pero ahorita nada más lo hice
para que veas que esta no es una idea
tan complicada y alocada bueno a lo
mejor si es complicada pero pero no es
alocada nos vemos